[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLT MCANLIS: Understanding how
to make a great performing app
has everything to do
with understanding
what's going on under the hood.
If you don't know what
the hardware is doing,
you've got a good chance
of using it poorly.
My name is Colt
McAnlis, and when
it comes to rendering
your application,
understanding how Android
is utilizing the GPU
can go a long way to
understanding your performance
problems.
The main question is this--
how does your activity actually
get drawn to the screen?
Or rather, how does all that
crazy XML and markup language
turn into pixels that the
user can see and understand?
At its core, this is done with a
process known as rasterization.
This is the process of
taking some high level
object like a string or a
button or a path or a shape
and turning it into pixels in
the texture or on your screen.
Now, rasterization is a really,
really time consuming process.
And as such there's
a special piece
of hardware in
your mobile device
that's designed to make
it happen a lot faster.
The graphics processing
unit, or GPU,
was introduced to mainstream
computers back in the '90s
to help accelerate the
rasterization process.
The GPU itself is
designed to use
a specific set of primitives,
dominately polygons
and textures, or as you
may call them, images.
And your CPU is responsible
for feeding these primitives
to your GPU before
it can actually
draw anything to the screen.
This is done with a
common API on Android
known as OpenGL ES, which
means that any time your UI
objects like buttons
or paths or checkboxes
need to be drawn to
the screen, they first
need to be converted on the
CPU to polygons and textures
before being passed off
to the GPU to rasterize.
And, as you would
imagine, this process
of converting a UI object into
a set of polygons and textures
is not really the
fastest of operations.
Likewise, needing to upload
it from the CPU to the GPU
really isn't that fast
either, which makes sense then
that you would want to reduce
the number of times you have
to convert an object as
well as the number of times
you have to upload
it for drawing.
Now, thankfully,
OpenGL ES API allows
you to upload content to
the GPU and leave it there.
When you'd like to draw a
button again in the future,
you simply need to reference
the mesh that's already
resident in GPU memory and just
tell OpenGL how to draw it.
The general rule is
this-- optimizing
for rendering performance means
getting as much data on the GPU
as fast as possible
and then leave it there
without modifying it
for as long as possible.
See, every time you update a
resource that's on the GPU,
you're losing precious
processing time.
And this is a rule that the
Android system lives by--
to make rendering performant.
For example, resources that are
provided by your theme-- that
is bitmaps and drawables--
are grouped together
into a single texture
and uploaded to the GPU
on your behalf alongside
commonly used polygon meshes
like nine patches.
This means that
any time you draw
a view that uses
these resources,
we don't have to
do any conversion.
See, all the content is
already resident on the GPU,
making these type of views
really fast to display.
However, this process
gets more and more complex
as UI objects get more
and more advanced.
For example, displaying
images, means
loading these images
on the CPU into memory
and then transferring them
over to the GPU to draw.
Using paths creates
a whole separate mass
as we might need
to actually create
a chain of polygons in the CPU.
Or even make a masking
texture on the GPU
that approximates the shape.
Drawing text is like a
complete double whammy.
I mean, think about it.
On the CPU side we actually
have to rasterize the glyphs
to a texture and then
upload that over to the GPU,
and then go back and for
each character in our string,
draw a rectangle that references
those glyphs on the GPU memory.
And animations can make this
whole thing even more complex.
See, depending on how you're
changing your visuals,
you may have to incur all the
overhead of updating your GPU
resources again and again
and again every single frame.
And this doesn't even cover all
the other crazy GPU performance
stuff.
For instance, rather than
redrawing the whole application
every frame, Android
saves performance
by only updating and drawing
the area of the screen that's
actually been modified, not
to mention all the CPU side
conversions and
uploads that Android
has to go through
to get everything
ready to render in
a performant manner.
But here's the
tricky part, in order
to provide a smooth,
luscious user experience,
you have to accomplish all
the code updates, GPU resource
updates, and final rendering
in 16 milliseconds per frame
of your animation-- every frame.
Or at least that's
the goal, which
is why you need to check out the
rest of the Android Performance
Patterns content to help
supercharge the rendering
pipeline in your application.
Oh, and don't forget to join
our Google+ community for other
great tips and tricks and
advice from more developers.
As always, keep calm,
profile your code,
and remember, perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]